if this comes up I'm going to be shocked
oh my goodness it came up okay there is
a Street in Beverly Hills in Los Angeles
called Ferrari drive and there's an
amazing Lookout which you can kind of
tell from what I'm hopefully you can see
this I feel like a weather broadcaster
like or something um there's an amazing
view and when I first started dating an
ex-boyfriend of mine we drove up there
it was like our first kiss and um we
watched the sunrise together and I
actually wrote a song about this night
called Ferrari drive that like never saw
the light of day but we watched the
sunrise there and I think that might be
one of the only times I've ever stayed
up and watched a sunrise I've never
pulled an all nighter in my life isn't
that crazy ever I was always like the
first kid to sleep at a sleepover if
everyone was sleeping in the basement
together and it was like a big slumber
party whoever's house it was I was like
I'm sleeping in your bedroom you all
have fun down here so that was me so I
never really watched a sunrise except
for this one night